now for another important thing
when we calculate the quality of
australian teachers
by averaging sports for intelligence
richness
and attractiveness
teaches for
11
every time
now perfect i need you to show me love
for us
incredible
gorgeous teachers not to mention my own
ridiculously bewitching looks
all right siri um well i do have to say
i think we'd happily abolish school
holidays just to spend another hour with
our school
teachers harry that's ludicrous only
school holidays
i would give up weekends just to be here
or some teachers
guys you're all just all talk no action
let's have an episode of thank god
you're here with mr roo
come on up
words
i'm so ready for this
bring it
i see i see you're in 80s attire today
will there be any 80s references in your
performances
speaks for
itself enough very nice i noticed that
there's some kind of um inter-faculty
rivalry here possibly
i'm i'm going to judge who's going to
win this so everyone wants to offer a
bribe right now
how do mass marks look right now jeffrey
what are the two units
all right well i think that they're
ready for you now so give up give a big
welcome to mr
you